Okay, okay, okay, okay,
at the dock for you guys. In the dialectical
materialism of Marxist-Leninist philosophy, there are six
basic categories to reflect the
fundamental attributes and relationships of
things and phenomena. In this video,
I will share with you the
categories of the particular and the general. The
video content will cover the concepts of the particular, the
general, and the singular, the relationship
between the particular, the general, and the singular, and
finally, the meaning of this relationship.
I will use many relatable examples
so that you can easily understand.
If you find this video helpful,
please give it a like, subscribe to the
channel, and leave a comment in the comments section.
First, let's
explore the categories of the particular, the general, and the singular. The particular
is a category used to refer to
a specific thing, phenomenon, or
process. The general is a
category used to refer to attributes and
aspects that are similar and repeated
in different things. The singular is a
category used to refer to aspects.  The
characteristics that are unique to this object or phenomenon
and not found in other objects or phenomena—
that's how you understand it, but
actually, it's simpler. Can you explain it like
this? For example, we have object/
phenomenon A and object/phenomenon B.
Each object/phenomenon has its own unique characteristics.
These are the unique aspects
that A has and B
also has. If they coincide, then they are the commonalities. And those aspects that are unique to
A and B are the unique ones. Similarly, for any other object/phenomenon, it's the unique aspects of A
and B. Let's take an
example: replace
student Nguyen Van A with Le Van B.
Nguyen Van A is a
unique individual, and Le Van B is also
a unique individual. These two students
will have similar attributes,
such as being students, having the same
gender, or being the same age.
These similarities are the
commonalities of the two unique aspects A and B,
while the unique aspects are those that are unique to either A or
B.  It's just about that. For example,
your fingerprint.
This fingerprint only exists in one place. It doesn't exist in the North, nor in any other place or
phenomenon.
Each person's fingerprint is different. Secondly,
within the scope of three rivers—the Mekong
River, the Red River, the
Mekong River, the Red River—there are three
distinct and three common aspects, these are the aspects, the
attributes. Meeting again in all three
rivers, all three rivers will have a
constant flow of water.
The unique aspect, for example, is the Nile River, the
longest river in the world at
6639 km. No other river has
this attribute. So, this is the unique aspect
of the Nile River. Easy to understand, right?
Next, about the relationship between the
particular, the general, and the unique. Firstly,
the general only exists for the particular
through the particular and expresses
its existence, meaning there is no general. It exists
outside of the particular. I'll
give an example: there is no
common river that exists outside of
rivers like the Nile.  The Red River compared to other
rivers or any other specific river,
but all specific rivers
have water and flow.
This common characteristic is repeated in
the rivers of Vietnam and is reflected
in the concept of a river. Clearly,
the common exists, but it does not
exist outside of the individual. The amount of money is
through the individual. Secondly, the individual
only exists in relation to the
common, meaning that no individual
exists absolutely independently without a
connection to the common. For example, each person
is an individual, but each
person cannot exist outside
of society and nature.
There is no individual that is not subject to the
influence of the common, which is
biological laws or social laws.
Thirdly, the individual is the whole, richer than
the common. The common is a part,
but more profound than the individual.
For example, in the context of a classroom, if there are
8 students, these 8
students are 8 different, with diverse and
rich nuances.  They are similar in terms of
personality, appearance, and abilities,
but they still share a commonality: they are all
young,
knowledgeable, and undergoing professional training.
This deeply reflects the nature
of these students. Therefore, the commonality
is a part, but more profoundly, it's
a connection. Fourthly, the unique and the
common can transform into each other in
the process of physical development. In the
development of organisms,
variations appear in
different ways, and this is the unique.
After the scene changes, it can
become suitable, and this characteristic, that is,
the unique, will be preserved and maintained across
many generations and become common to
many individuals. That is, it will become the
common. Conversely,
common but unsuitable characteristics will gradually disappear
and become the unique. Based on the
concepts and relationships above,
we can draw the
following meanings: firstly, the common only
exists within the individual through the
cross to express its existence.  The
commonalities can only be found through
individual things and phenomena that
do not originate from subjective
human desires. Secondly, the commonalities are
profound, essential; one must rely on the
commonalities to improve
practical activities. Without understanding these
commonalities, one will inevitably
fall into
blind, indiscriminate action. Thirdly, under
certain conditions, the particular can
become the common, and vice versa. Therefore,
in practical activities, it is necessary to create
favorable conditions for the individual to actively participate.
Yes, the commonalities and
negative commonalities become the particulars.
I have just shared with you about the categories of the
particular and the general. If you found
this video helpful,
please give me a like and leave a
comment below. If you are interested, please
subscribe to the channel and hit the bell to receive
notifications about the latest videos. I will release
many videos on the subject of the
basic principles of Marxism-Leninism.
Now, goodbye and see you in the
next video!
[music]